this is our last debate club what's up
guys spice from knoxville tennessee
and uh brandon i know you like to go
fast and feel i know you've got a thick
ass so
[Laughter]
real big boy club
yeah i wish dawg i wish i jumped on a
hog and feel comfortable they're too
dangerous though man
and i need a workout son i feel like
you've been on motorcycles no
yeah i've been a motorcycle before man
i've had a couple of occurrences i got
thrown off of one
on the side of like a hill one time
pretty dangerous i'm trying to make
funny obama assuming you're the guy in
the back holding your buddy
i was in one of those side cars one time
and somebody set it on fire when i was
in there
yeah and so that was a little bit spooky
what was his debate club just
motorcycles motorcycles are bicycles
oh bicycle you're trying to get lean and
mean bicycles son motorcycle doing all
the work
it's like that e-bike i didn't even
sweat just
yeah mountain i did on the bike this
weekend it's definitely not the
it's not the rough and tumble thing you
want you try and get them quad teardrop
hitters you got to get on that bike and
put in the work son
get that blowout ass like theo you gotta
put in the work jesus christ
put the work somewhere else dude it's
all on my butt
that dude looked dope on a bike though
they do look fun
he looks sweet on that bike didn't he i
could see chappelle being on a hug
yeah she's like see you fellas i told
you i've been binge watching sons of
anarchy
yeah get out there man you got to get
out there dude get in the hell's angels
okay yeah they don't let black people in
there huh
but change the name is that a rule is
that a rule
i yeah i think so no black people in
hell's angels are they racist
no who's the all black one not the hmong
black panthers
not the black panthers because they
don't have motorcycles um there's an
all-black one there there's some bad
boys dude
i don't think i'll know that type in all
black uh motorcycle gang i see i see him
in bed motorcycle club
they're not a game not a gang call me
gang get shot in the face black
motorcycle club
black rebel nope no black rebels
that's a band or maybe look up at maybe
try african-american
maybe just type in black motorcycle
black motorcycle gang
it's black motorcycle game you're right
you're right just typing gang for the
sake of it i mean i'm not
i'm not calling a gang but that's you
got to put in buffalo soldiers it says
nope that's not who i'm thinking of
doing
it's a big one yeah that's a big one
well f you guys man because
i'm trying to meet some hot chicks dude
dude they have hot chicks they're called
they're called uh
old ladies they're old ladies and they
and they gotta wear their names on their
back of their
property of yeah it's sick property of
anna
do they have a lot of vietnamese um
bikers motorcyclists
yeah that's all we do over in vietnam
everyone drives a motorcycle
oh [ __ ] i actually have a burn on my leg
from motorcycle when i was in vietnam
i got burned by the exhaust pipe when i
was like six damn
it's like a rite of passage almost kind
of yeah i think it's the vandals
is that on there look when you vandals
is a band
when you and nick are done flirting with
each other uh
the rest of us are trying to find out
about vietnamese bicyclists
what are we looking up about
just do me a favor because i'm off today
is it the vandals
because i saw on the road as a black
there you go vandals mc yes
oh pagans motorcycle club no the vandals
that's them dude
yeah i saw a couple on the road they
meet
they meet in venice and i was scared and
i looked them up um
those are white people vandals those are
a lot of white guys
i don't think i don't know i don't think
one's exist i don't even know
i know tiramisu i'll tell you that much
really i know tiramisu
well theo i'm glad you got some rest man
you're the only guy i knew that need a
vacation during the quarantine
man i'm exhausted bro i'm gonna take off
for a few days like
from what oh [ __ ] it is true
dude dude oh you know what i did see so
a lot of the businesses were closed
they had deer just like wandering around
like
inside of like uh just parking lots and
stuff things you would be like oh this
is like a weird place for some deer
they had a uh like a la quinta inn
and by the pool and stuff they had deer
just drinking out of it
pretty crazy they're getting a little
too comfortable yeah
deer up in the hot tub
then mormons get back to work let me
lighten those deer up
oh yeah man choke them out yeah dude
i would love to start a male all male or
also some chase can come
um no you want it all male keep going
where you fight animals where people we
have to fight animals one-on-one or hunt
one-on-one with your hands yeah or with
a knife
one knife
that sounds like you think it would do
it sounds like naked and afraid but just
boys but also chicks can come at night
i'm in yeah but do you think people
would do it
no too scared to kill what were you
gonna kill with your bare hands
right it's tough a couple warthogs maybe
snakes
but there'd be some you really see who
could be some good hunters
you have to grapple them [ __ ] murder
hornets dude or go noodling
well that's right put your hand in the
[ __ ] catfish mouth it's catfish right
yeah yeah that's popular in vietnam
isn't it no that's new orleans
i feel like oh yeah i know it's popular
down there but i'm talking about i've
seen it done a bunch in louisiana
mississippi
oklahoma does it big time